please welcome Katherine Heigl's
please forgive me I'm unbelievably
nervous I'm not very good at this um
over the last 27 years Oscars for makeup
have been awarded to artists who created
vampires werewolves cavemen fierce
warriors with beautiful blue faces and
apes who speak English they work very
long hours go home covered in muck and
have altogether too much fun the
nominees are
DDA Lavanya and Jan Archibald for La Vie
en Rose
Rick Baker and Kazuhiro Tsuji for Norbit
v mu and Martin Samuel for Pirates of
the Caribbean at World's End and the
Oscar goes to
DDA Livonia in gen Archibald for La Vie
en Rose
this is the first Academy Award for DDA
Lavinia and Jan Archibald
thank you very much thank you at the
academy and what can I say I'm really
happy and proud be here with you bye so
thank you to the Academy for this huge
honor I'm overwhelmed it's just amazing
but I have a lot of people to thank my
assistants particularly my Czech crew
the worked with us in Prague and in
Paris they were amazing they worked very
hard and I owe a lot to them and just
it's so exciting to be here don't know
what to say thank you